hello welcome to GameSpot's coverage of
e3 2016 we are live on the gamespot
stage brought to you by airheads I'm
your host Daniel Dwyer joined by peter
brown and we're very happy to start off
six hours of talking about video games
with the game director from square enix
hijima how are you doing sir yeah doing
xmas no I get so much to buy the Sun for
coming on today was at the audio
designers nobody at the [ __ ] man thank
you thank you and Gavin as well for
translating over the next decade and
September it's coming out what does it
feel like being so close to the release
that's funny people today more we did
okay emo told me keep on disconnect mmm
hysteria leukemia tell Cara ano koro
have cashier indicate oh whatever mother
my check on tony so cool cosimo Iran the
promotion amaura tell cara senza origami
takako 98 no I mean he's coming up to
release so you can't see that final goal
there but it certainly doesn't feel like
we come with the enzyme so much
development work left to do and so many
promotional things I've got be involved
with so it really feels like I'm still
hard at it I'm afraid yeah it's only a
couple of months until it said what's
your e 3 like is it mostly just doing
media stuff and then you're going back
to develop straightaway super get sued
the CEO move adidas kodomo no sorry
promotion Oh katsu domain in are
disgusting to know what their sobriety
I'm attic I had the early Sunday so III
my occasional show no cry site you a
promotional mania there misurata new
home theater district items me to you
and I arigato service is Monsieur John
Turk new now I just pretty much like I
always do when I come on these ships is
well I'm here during a show we're doing
a promotional stuff but then obviously
dealing with you find at the same time
then when i go back it straight back
into doing the development work he had
two more it's been wonderful seeing a
more gameplay comed for Final Fantasy 15
over the past couple of years and
especially here at e3 as well and what
are you showing off here at e3 that we
haven't seen before suunto stay our
motto con carne III they don't own
donkey em pray no katachi me tienes que
toma de coca an attendee sora no doy
como dijo con carne an own game company
no hajimete a no so no console man no
hands on the stainless neck we're
actually putting up the first actual
hands-on demo
console versions of the game this year
mmm forget to emmaus that that's the
main thing we're showing to you what's
it like seeing people pick it up and
play as have you watched people you
teeny total praise there too no meteor
initial kinetic you initial korekara me
lekar am Erato timidity 9 naked amor
dame hasta llegar a no settings return
when you put a stereo mrs. D'Amato token
you are Santa chanted wait another
second if that Nagi got the public other
people playing it yeah go see that's all
starting soon start today but I was
watching all the staff of our company
stuff picking up and playing it when
doing the setup phase and it really do
feel good to see where it's actually up
there people are playing it now it's
real to me know yeah it's not scary is
that a scary proposition because it's a
game that's been people have been
anticipating for so so long I mean
you're so close to the finish line is it
does it feel good at this point or is it
is it intimidating oh yeah no more no
coloring a great insight exterior title
there are no there no more design equal
vigor got a limit or not they're not
quite keeping the one denies connect to
the show how can a quick even when I
quedo a no material achieve a negative
Regina kamata Cara Sun Joon Encana Kenny
cota rica talkative who are chosen a
team of Spencer I'm not particularly
frightened or afraid of such but
certainly I mean the people who've been
waiting long is this game they've been
waiting around 10 years for it now so
I'm just wondering maybe a little bit
unsure am I gonna be able to meet the
expectations these people were going for
such a long time so it's maybe more
towards a little bit unsure about that
Decker episode juventa Geneva que una
cosa nyonya Recodo sent via text ayer
keroh masoli me a coke I whatever naku
have a vm cargo today Kyoto my nose but
i'm really happy pulling out all the
stops and doing everything we can on the
game so we don't we don't feel that
we've left anything out or we've we've
shot sold ourselves short so i think
that we can be confident and going
towards that final race now i think
we've done our best to be really i put
everything it's making the game
wonderful let's talk about is the final
finest 50 individuals are looking at it
right here I had how does this
difference were the final fantasy games
obviously we're talking about an open
world and I want to be going to see in
terms of like moments moment action guy
open world you go today a new body to
find a French canary check out on
Mondays kedamono donae'o numero uno
cards will do no yona an oxygen tank i
cavalieri sukhani mosque on Kaiba protea
tavern karima definer Montecito potent
art OH
each of uncertain have brought you I
think the actual first approach the real
main way we approach creating the game
is quite different to previous final
fantasies honka I'm as a straight or and
more each day don't take in a sec I out
Scutaro ichiban sighs when he approached
to stay where he must our first priority
in this new approach is to create a
existing living believable world really
moves in his own way and in its
independent of the player in that that
was the first thing that we did someone
scare at Ithaca and avail Adventure
Malusi rodo tripping on suse a no action
combat officer CTO and gaming also no
mechanic 2mon on Oct that is cricketing
atoms and then the second thing we did
after we had that living believable
world was to add on top of that all the
adventures you have in the world and the
road trip aspect of it in the action
battle combat and add these gameplay
elements on top of that world and make
the second layer of the game not again
dosti Masuku mode on na levanto
cormaneau classic Naboo punto you go to
go to addiction Jenica not the kind of
everything we have managed to get that
fusion of the classic traditional kinds
of final fantasy elements also this
really new modern kind of gameplay stuff
as well yeah is there is there a sort of
a business reason behind that as well
because obviously final fantasy has a
massive fan base but it's quite an
insular fan base as well but you know
the sort of wider world of action games
are you trying to pull people into final
Mariano final 22 months ago a donation
fan base are in the SkyDome Oh No Mas
humming can I cocky right there cuz much
too touchy there are no they no business
taking the new moto them out in the sky
national parks on gay Montana seems to
touch more and conquer y tener eternity
joker mojo so the snare I know at Recife
creation agarra Coronado venimos carrito
Manzo quest emerald icon muzica shift at
zoo staff no return and Aikido more
sorrow contain Honka Honka mock UN
Septimus that's pretty much exactly
right i mean it's a bit difficult
balance to get right but we want to
satisfy the the pre-existing fans the
core fans of the series and also reach
out to make new people as well so i
think we are trying very hard and it is
making it looking to be good success on
the approach this time tokina conca III
no naka de know johan Alaska tottenham
oh so I so know why don't I start at
sequel crap at respond at Emerald
tamanna why Donna yo ho toh why dem
kanojo photo so no qualms kanojo to Naga
a no yo ho yo e estabas and certainly
with the country information and stuff
we're putting our e3 this year we've got
two very different
and focuses for that we've got a lot of
information which will appeal to that
new wider audience people who we want to
become fans of final fantasy and then
there's other information aimed at the
people who are already traditional fans
and to satisfy those people as well so
we're aiming for both groups a leader
I'm sorry Nick you know know Microsoft
oh I know Sony no sorry sir no
confidence no joke hola yeah pre a no
fuss no party no conference all day y de
la vie de Makino joho the kill Kara no
issue in a can chua epic well quanah
cute anymore mon Dieu quiz tomorrow
terminal GOP so it mean separate the
simple we separated out i mean the
information we put out yesterday at the
Sony Microsoft first party conferences
I'm very much for the wider audience
there to get the message out and then as
we move through III the information we
can release today and over the next
couple of days is perhaps aimed a bit
more of that traditional fan group okay
yeah Peter you kind of represent both of
those in my head you're a fan of final
fantasy and you're also somebody who
loves games like Metal Gear Solid quite
a lot and you have any questions for the
guys about this little million yeah one
of the things that really attracts me to
certain final fantasy games are the
themes in the story and I understand
that Noctis is dealing with you know
troubles his family are facing but I'm
wondering if you can detail some of the
other themes in the game that we will
experience as we go on this adventure I
don't know what else you're going to
find the fancy huh no dice ii desu kedo
mo ano final french banks career motto
proc due to the snare and rapists or you
know and of chi tema not even the conch
I an evocative Noctis todo caso con otra
por tu kar komak kon keno monochromatic
Olinsky da friggin no te MOA and konkani
high-tension my ichiban natashka Aunt
Emma tutto ciò a tinactin oh so no voy
con okies Nicki Minaj hakuna sta SE cho
ki te kooti to coeur de la reine des
cadeaux mo sono wanna haveta cool Oh
Yuri sky story in cerita many dr. Tanaka
matakana Yokosuka no kisne mo astoria
nicoletto DiMaggio element ersatz
cutomers okay I mean as you mentioned
the the core theme for the story is very
much that relationship noctis with his
father regis and how that plays out but
in order to really strengthen that core
theme and widen it at the same time
that's the vertical relationship that
we've also looking at the horizontal
relationships going out between Noctis
and his three companions on his journey
and that really does a reinforcement and
tie into the whole story there's one mmm
i'm also very curious about the VR demo
that you showed yesterday that came is a
very big surprise and I'm curious win
that idea came to fruition and how long
you've been working the Apple
Tino Tenkaichi closet on OVR dame amor
co nghia nokia tansy a pneumatically
stay at reseda Stanga today it's a green
energy tanker collected shoka eaten
every year no kenkyu Geneva II gato en
cara I know suzuka tienes mucha nazo im
so kinky dinner yet the master okay
we've actually been researching doing
experimentation with be off quite a
while now i think we actually started
looking at it about a year ago when we
side so the course of illness or Hitler
said to that are cure the most written
as you do in cash there at the King
Jewish the town's name and obviously you
are all different brands of headset in
the VR companies making be our devices
and we really have looked at working on
all of those the PS we are in can stay
on Tony sky know conoco aqui que no
hanashi Oh hit a light on Allah books i
kin there totemo musica is you can day
at auto thermal scan in the day quan chi
1 0 demos a sacristy muscle and then for
the psv our demo that we released we
showed yesterday that was actually great
in a very short period of time with a
very small break away team from the main
team so we am actively working on that
particular one for very long at all all
right so no mother seeking to my staff
with my mother like a doubt so question
are you on the high knees come away at
it in India I mean cuz we haven't
actually mastered up the main game yet
so we really had to make sure a team and
what their activities to the side
weren't affecting the process to get the
main game done so we very much took care
of that ass aluminum on em khong cai no
hunting ye ye shi zai qu na kayo more i
turn up the unit on caucus but i feel we
read you have a really great opportunity
to try something and to get that out of
this time was it difficult to begin
developing in something that's so
different because I've heard developers
discuss things like you know a certain
scale of objects you have to adjust
because the depth of field in
perspective is so different your
relationship changes to the environment
how has it been adapting to that new
format what does Iran declared server
kunis kiddo yeah hurry so no no quickie
no show again to car so you object to
know mano skating look at this new york
did you take a mandar tomo nice kodomo
sonoma we are my decision he tossed in
MO no no chi hottini transitory hari
wrote on discussing our home on desk i
kigali shoka sosna we are on a dock
token also know scary gah shantou so not
yet acepto stato kini Ganges Soneji
scary muzzle Iowa City Coto de hecho
esto no no step two step there sorry
Cara given domain Oh Kankakee square
toes donkey konga nabiyeen can see
Rihanna
you stay cool demo I know speco
calculate an ecology cynacian a cake and
I know they're so now Kim be organic in
oth the st. i could do you know Sosuke
go under because I'm can 0 ty Kenya's at
the chef in Turkey steak potato corn on
Olga k co co that you don't know thank
you muah catechin no I mean we have
learned a lot recently especially about
how to make VR games certainly the first
thing you have to do is to get that
scale to fit with what you expect from
from a natural views with the naked eye
and then that that depiction of how the
world should look into really where the
eyes move as well how you can do that
kind of visual field and gain obviously
we can't develop in an unlimited spec
there's a technical limitations of what
you can do to fit that in and get that
very realistic sort of appeal and
perspective in there is something that
we had we have learned a lot about in
working on it will people be people who
purchase Final Fantasy 15 and
playstation 4 get the VR experience that
you showed yesterday or do they have to
purchase it separately ya no se Co jock
sorry i don't kill enemy secrets at that
we are a no de memoria de lenovo note
and oh kudi hot spiced with you colonel
budahas pacific american idol i was
never a comedy konkan ademola 15 oconee
secreta con esta claro funny san
Antonio's clear not amo te le kundo puto
Deus name none de hecho say him bond oh
dear she can i canna cottage irritate
your stain a ppm that we aren't thinking
about marketing as a separate product at
all it really is something extra to be
enjoyed by the people who purchased the
game so we think you're probably going
to be a dlc release later for the game
or something like that ok yeah vs
effective at me Narvik Mizuki
samaritaine after you Noah an actual
store uttered Cartman takayanagi
tanoshinde who she napped in a so good
Nick pony are con- now it really is our
core beliefs as the two things first of
all we should satisfy the people who buy
the game that we've made as much as
possible and we also wanted to play for
as long as possible too so it really
does help with that give them something
extra we'll provide any story details or
is it purely like a side activity that
doesn't impact the players understanding
of the mark we are demo to Noah story
taken ago so MA abacus orito muchas de
anoche ah no shoo me no game play guitar
America to chew on the show so eastland
ask a question and you Ares on a story
no she rocks at iona nay you added to
junior
if so the kano de receitas and then
connect at CMS now it's actually the
Bulldogs had a very different way to
substandard story expansion base dlc
it's not like ideal scenario now on the
Akuma day she's a clear RC Brielle negan
tasty a totai counts good to me that we
are saying on contents the second idea
Tim it's good to meet mo na we really
did just look at it as a game play
experience it weren't something that we
could create to use the strength of VR
create something you can only do with VR
and it's still very much a prototype in
a work in progress but that was that was
the main aim for the game on our lucha
vavoom lord I but I can they killed Todd
or a cretinous Tyga I know as you wear
naka de Coteau at perot systems I mean
the difference we took was to take one
section of the main game itself and then
how can we make this as fun as possible
and as great an experience as possible
if you played it in VR its side from
that ready it's such a big project
obviously the game has been worked on
for years there's extended universe
stuff with movies in the anime and why
not butttt about a son what is the one
thing that you were the most proud of in
Final Fantasy 15 alimony nagar IDK i had
start extinguish theta chi sono
university must know sake inglemoor
orinda CA thomas oh no sweetie no naka
de chopin sangano horny teen cuisine de
abajo cornea motor baut go bananas yoga
see better naka de la civetta no naka de
wah I know Eric 15 to you khong cai
maintain erson game wall side again use
an amazing talents in the moral Tammany
sue paterno universe God soon as I
stated to toga pulla okayama muskoka
maha quita esta y como tamika's natural
to me Oh cor de que no keepo deaerated
quinoa's goku water aqua katakana
between characters name now i'm
personally for my view of everything i
think it's that universe series of
products in itself and to be able to
have them to expand on and allow people
to enjoy the core game experience in it
is wide and has broad away as possible
and this is a completely new kind of
approach for us and to be able to do
this kind of thing on such a scale
that's never we've never done before
really just to do that is something i
think it's a surprising and it's a it's
just a really really great thing to do
so i'd say that whole universe set
products as which tie into the game i
can like with a yogurt them or mechanic
at it again shania ESCA have to buy
naman Iran domino zumba stay tanoshimi
sudeikis routine oh la casa y me levanto
new coach its again tectonic tuna so
cool
hakuouki mangeshkar de Tigre turn up if
you know I mean you often get these
things you got lots of great ideas in
your head you think about it it's very
rare that you get to do them and make
them reality right so certainly being
able to get that already and done before
the release of the game and get out as
the whole wide experience and certainly
that also i feel that was a great thing
that we could have done and also the
help and the the efforts of all the key
people working on those different
projects really has come to fruition i
think wonderful just in time September
30th the game is at butter son
congratulations on Final Fantasy 15 the
best of luck with the rest of
development yeah re other animals also
had to bite you cuddle day I know so
crew got two sons you need to go today
nobody know al Qaeda Chicago Syndic was
like yo I got to thank you very much
thank you thank you Gavin as well thank
you for you yeah we'll be back in just a
few minutes vince i'm paula zahn to talk
about titanfall 2 so make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot see in a second you're
watching the game spot stage brought to
you by airheads
you